- [Interviewer] All right Maddy.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Maddy, where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Maddy] I grew up in
Walnut Creek, California
- [Interviewer] Up North?
- [Maddy] Yeah Bay area.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood,
did you have both your
parents when you were young?
- Well, I'm adopted and
I was taken at birth
and so I went into foster care
and I was hit throughout foster care.
So my adopted mom got me originally
there was a couple that came along
and wanted to adopt me but I was too sick,
I had ear infections that were killing me.
And when my adopted mom got me,
she took me into doctors
got surgery on my ears
'cause I needed two replacements.
So I dealt with being a traumatized child
from the beginning of birth.
- [Interviewer] From
your first foster family?
- I think I went from foster
family to foster of family.
I think it was in like maybe
five to 10 different homes
before I was even two cause
I kept coughing all the time.
Then instead of like taking me to doctors
they would just hit me to shut me up.
- [Interviewer] So eventually
you ended up with a family
that was stable and...
- I was in a like, they
were looking for a family
to adopt me like the first family
didn't wanna adopt me cause I was sick.
I was so sick and they said,
"Oh, a sick child we
don't want this child."
And then after that
my adopted mom came along
and she adopted me cause
she really love babies
but she didn't love like the
part of the person growing up
'cause it was her losing control.
She wanted to feel wanted.
But she adopted me and
took me to the doctor,
got me ears fixed and I was
deaf and until I was about two.
So I had no speech, no
hearing, no nothing.
I learned it really late.
So in school I went to
speech for about eight years
and I couldn't say things
like basic words like computer
or napkin or napkin or paper towels.
It was a fresh start to learn
how to talk but just like,
and then she raised me as a single mother,
adopted me as single mother.
At the time I had two parents
but he wasn't actually my parent.
He was just around when I was adopted.
So he became like my father.
He was my father though.
He wasn't my adopted
father or my blood father,
but he was family.
And family's really important to me.
I remember that after I was
probably like five years old
my mom kicked him out
cause he was an alcoholic
'cause she wanted to control him,
had severe control issues.
And so I went through like
the abandonment of two parents separated
and that was really
really difficult for me.
And then after that my mom had like
these two guys came to our house
and was like Sky has nowhere
to stay can you stay with you?
And that was the beginning
of my childhood rape.
I went four years of being starved,
four years of being hit with metal bar,
four years of being hit with a horse whip,
four years of sexual rape,
four years of being locked in a room,
four years of being tied to a bed,
four years of just childhood trauma
that can't be taken back but
it's made me who I am today.
My mom ended up finding
someone she wanted to marry
and with this guy, I just remember
he treated me like I was adult to him.
Like I was something he
could put in the bathtub
and shave my legs, get angry
and hit me when he wanted.
He would like do all
kinds of nasty sexual play
after I was always with
like, even before school like
remember before kindergarten,
he take me to the gas station
and he would like pick up
magazines of trans women
and trans men and show me at that age
and he showed me what my first
vibrating dildo was at five.
I remember I walked into school
and I was telling other kids
what a vibrator was like a dildo,
because I didn't understand
why I would get in trouble.
And I went in and they said,
"you can't say that kind of stuff,
or I'll have to suspend you."
But like, where were the teachers thinking
like, why would a kid be saying that?
Did they ask any questions?
I remember I went to school
one day and I told teacher,
"Hey, look, I'm being
touched, I'm being hit."
And they checked my body and
he didn't see any bruises
so they had sent me home with the guy
that was doing it to me.
And that guy ended up telling me,
and if I told anybody that he would
take my mom and me hanging from a tree,
cut her open in front of
me and then cut me open
and I would have to watch her bleed.
- [Interviewer] And this was
your adopted mom's boyfriend?
- Yeah, this was just the beginning.
- [Interviewer] And this started,
the sexual part of it started
when you were about five?
- Probably like the beginning
of five, four, five.
So it went from that to
my stepdad moving in,
holding a guy, right?
And I remember that he wasn't a bad guy
but tension started
because I remember that
the first night was great
but after that first guy,
that the guy that abused
me my mom brought around.
I promised myself I'd
always hate my stepdad.
I'd always hate him.
I always look at him as he's
evil, as he's a bad man.
And he wasn't a bad man,
but I learned as I got older
and my mom manipulated me
and his situation to see
it as something that wasn't
because she would get jealous
that he would take me out shopping
and it wasn't her and she'd
pick fights between us.
And it was manipulating
because we both didn't see it that way.
And I realized if I had given him a chance
and that hadn't happen he
would be different in my life.
But it came to the point where it was like
I made him so angry and
he made me so angry.
He'd get violent with me like
I remember in elementary school,
he would pick me up and
push me against the wall
and shake me and I told the school
and they told him he
can't do that anymore.
So he stopped now.
And I went from that to like
him looking down my shirt
and I was afraid like,
maybe he would rape me
or maybe he would poison me
because he wanted my mom.
And I just experienced a lot of jealousy
between my stepdad and my mom.
And I think my mom was
made with him for 14 years.
And when I was 12,
the guy that was at the
house started treating me
like his daughter not the rapist.
When I was in the house,
they was on drugs out of it.
It was a drug house, especially
and I remember this one
guy he was pretty sober
he smoked cigarettes
and he took care of me.
He showed me my first
computer, what Nickelodeon was,
we'd go outside.
And like I was a kid,
I loved insects, I liked
to collect butterflies
and lady bugs, what kid doesn't?
And I remember when I was 12,
I remember that I got
a call from the cops.
My mom did, and I was in the car.
And they said to me that
he had killed himself.
And I remember that I asked myself,
I always loved him while
when he come and tell me
that you like cared about me.
I would have been there for him.
I would have always cared about him.
I've always been instill am
the girl with the good heart
that would be there for a friend instant
if they were up fucked up
or trying to kill themselves
or commit suicide, I
would be that one person.
I'd run a mile to like get on
a plane and just find them.
But I just remember
like I couldn't believe
the one person that took care of me
through all that trauma was gone.
So that was really just made me upset.
And after that, my mom started taking in
like people that were like homeless
and that like couldn't
take care of themselves
and they won't take care of themselves.
My mom thought she could fix them.
Every guy that she's ever brought around
has been more important than her daughter.
And she felt like she could fix them.
She could fix anybody and
what she wasn't realizing
is she was damaging her own daughter.
She adopted me for whatever reasons
to not care that I was special,
not care that I had needs,
not care that I was a human,
a person living in this world
from young child and those men
that she was bringing around
were damaging me, hurting me,
in ways that no child at
all should go through rape.
No child at all should go through abuse.
No child at all should be
neglected from their food
or the rib cage is showing any child
not a foster care child.
Children deserve better and
adults sometimes deserve better.
but after the whole situation
with him killing himself,
my childhood rape, childhood
past, and my stepdad
by the time I was 14,
well, even before that
I was on online dating sites
because I didn't feel
safe to be at my own home
at this point.
I was jumping from house to house,
sleeping at random people's
house, just so I felt safe.
I felt safe with the random more.
I felt more safe with a random person
than I did at my own the home.
And then one time I got on there
and I started looking to seek help
from like finding somebody
to sleep at their house.
I was kidnapped for a week.
The guy drugged me up.
He was gonna take me to Mexico.
And then the cops showed
up at his house and said,
"we tracked you where's this girl at?"
They asked me if they knew the girl
'cause obviously they
knew that he had taken me.
And then he dropped me
off in front of my house
and I went inside and called the bed
'cause I was on Oxycontin.
He drugged me up.
I'd never been on drugs before.
I've never done weed.
I'd never drinking.
He gave me Oxycontin and he gave me Xanax.
And I just remember I passed out
and he was having sex with me
and he was probably like
27 years old and I was 14.
And I just remember being gone for a week
and being drugged up and being out of it.
And it was hard.
And then I'm sure that I
went to a boarding school,
a wilderness program.
My parents sent me away.
They woke me up at 3:00 am in the morning
to two big black woman
and a black man coming in.
And taking me at 3:00 am in the morning
and all I could think is,
why are two people taking
me early in the morning?
It wouldn't even matter
what color they are
like could be two big white people
and I'd be scared to.
I just got kidnapped
and my mom's paying these
people to come take me
and I'm like, thinking
who the fuck is she?
Who is she paying to come take
me at 3:00 am in the morning?
I thought I was gonna be
sex traffic at that point.
and my parents were conned or something.
So I'm waking up at 3:00 am in the morning
taken into a white van, like those vans,
it's called the sex trafficking vans,
the pedophile vans put in there
and get told I'm being put on
a plane and going somewhere.
They wouldn't tell me where.
And I'm thinking to myself like,
fuck what's gonna happen with my life?
Well, I ended up in a Wilderness program
about six months of that.
I was outdoors had backpack day height.
I went trailing and I
loved it all actually
I didn't wanna leave.
I didn't wanna go back to society.
I didn't wanna be a part of society.
I loved being outdoors so
much that I felt at home.
That was nice.
And so I did that and then
I went to a boarding school.
And I would run from
these boarding schools
'cause I felt forced to be
somewhere I didn't wanna be.
I don't let people force me
to be where I don't wanna be.
It's not who I am.
I'm my own goddamn person.
And so I just ran away.
I guess, after these boarding
schools, well, I ended up,
what I was gonna say is
I ended up taking a car.
I ran away from the boarding school,
ended up buying someone's
house that wasn't there
and I went took their car and
I drove back to California
from Idaho because I felt that
I'd never driven a car before.
I didn't have any directions.
I didn't have a map.
I didn't even know I could navigate
but I just got in the car and I drove it.
I drove it back to California.
Hour away from getting
where I wanted to go.
It was almost to freedom.
I got caught, I got pulled
over and they were like,
"Hey we have to take you to juvie."
And I was honest I was like,
"I don't have a permit or anything."
And I was like, "okay,
well you can arrest me now
'cause I'm not supposed
to be driving this car."
And so I went to juvie and
then my parents were like,
"we gotta come get her.
She must be out a boarding school."
Brought me back up there
and I tried to run again,
like when the SWAT was
when I got to gas station,
I tried to run again.
I didn't get away.
But then the detective actually,
they asked me to bring me
down to the police station
'cause they needed me
to talk to a detective.
And so I went down to the police station
and I told them the honest truth.
And then when it went to court.
I was just honest about it,
the judge actually
looked at me and was like
why are your parents putting
you in a boarding school?
You're way too smart for this.
It's like, you can get out of
and do something like that.
We don't really hear
about cases like this.
It's very rare that we
have an intelligent girl
that can out do that kind of stuff
and maybe your parents shouldn't
be putting you in programs
like this 'cause we don't
need like, cases like this.
So after that I went down
to a lockdown facility
it was called Cinnamon Hills
and they were really disturbing,
I feel like that what
they did was like rape.
They would take these kids once a month
these girls and these guys.
I think it was the girls,
I don't know about the
guys who separate us
but they take us into a doctor.
And they would like say that
we needed inspections every month.
And they'd sit there.
The doctor would say stuff like,
"Oh here comes the rubber
ducky spread your legs
from East to West.
I'm gonna stick my fingers up you now."
Every month he would penetrate
our vaginas with his fingers
and fill around.
And it was creepy and weird.
And they wouldn't let us
go see a normal doctor.
We had to see the one
that they chose for us.
We're allowed to go off
for maybe just the dentist,
but it was crazy and then,
what was gonna to say?
I think that was like
being there they would like
had a lot of mentally ill people.
And I was not one of them.
I would watch people do crazy stuff,
but I would be quiet and
just watching and observe.
If you got in trouble though,
they would like take you
and rip your arms off.
I was basically this
and they'd bend you over till you scream
and when you pee yourself.
And they'd scream in your face
and traumatized each person,
whether you were underage
children they were doing this too.
This was in Utah.
And they would just scream in your face.
And these people are here for trauma
but they would use that against them.
So it was like really bad to see that
that's the way that
people treat people like,
and whoever was running that
would allow that to happen.
But as I graduated from that school,
I went to another school
and started doing better.
The one thing that was crazy
is that since I was like five,
my teacher said,
"Oh, she's ADHD put her on meds."
So they put me on Adderall.
I think it was actually at four years old.
I was on Adderall.
And it really mentally
messed me up really early.
And then I went on like from med to med,
to med, to med, to med.
Every med has a negative side effect.
My mom never listened to me
about like how that affected me.
It was really awful.
And so I finally, when I was
out of the boarding schools
and I went through all that shit,
I ended up taking myself off of it.
I remember that feeling of...
I actually felt like I was myself.
How was a person?
I haven't been on med sense.
I don't touch drugs.
I don't touch meds.
I like being who I am.
I'm comfortable with myself.
And I feel confident within myself
because I don't let anything control me
that doesn't need to control me.
Not a person, not drugs, not people.
I am able to do what I wanna do in life
and know that I'm happy with myself.
I could walk out with
my hair all fucked up
and not care what people have to say,
because it's me, I'm just me.
Do you have a problem with
that? That's your own problem.
That's your own self projection.
Maybe you're worried about
how your hair will looks out
but that doesn't mean I'm you.
So that's how I was.
And then after that boarding school,
I came home and I met
this guy named Harrison
and he was working at the store,
actually across from my store.
- [Interviewer] And you're how old now?
- I'm 20, I'm think I'm 20 years old
and I'm home and I'm working at Safeway.
And this guy worked at Knob Hill
and it was crazy because,
we're friends we weren't
dating or anything,
we were like friend
and I remember going
on these days with them
everything was fine.
We weren't like in like in
a relationship relationship
at least I didn't think.
But I remember that he
was really nice to me,
I really liked him.
And I remember that he invited me
go up to his parents house.
And at his parents house
he forcefully raped me
by sticking his dick down my
throat and he wouldn't stop.
I pushed him off and he wouldn't stop.
And like two years later, I
think I was like 20, maybe 23,
I found out he raped
two other girls after me
at the same time and all those girls
are afraid to say something.
Honestly, it's like what
the guy did was awful
after one girl after another
girl, after another girl.
And now he's in the military,
but honestly, like he doesn't
deserve to be doing anything,
like, I don't know,
it's not my life though.
But it was the first time
that I really had PTSD.
I really was traumatized, fucked up.
And I was numb I couldn't
get a bed for six months.
I couldn't live, I didn't
feel like it could live,
but I was living.
I was damaged, but not
unfixable damage just damage
to like where it affected
me for a long time.
I was sleepwalking.
I was waking up traumatized.
So waking up with
nightmares, I was still in,
I was just so fucked up.
Still I sat there, I didn't
take drugs to get over it.
I sat there and I coped
with it as well as I could.
It's first time I've been
raped since my childhood
and then I was brought back
all the flashbacks of everything.
But I hadn't at the time, I ended up,
I was with somebody.
I ended up getting with my ex love.
He was my ex-boyfriend cause
I dated him for four years
from like 11 to 15.
And then, so I ended up
getting back with him
and at the time and he
ended up calling the cops
or I did call the cops, but
he stood by my side through it
and like helped me through it and stuff.
And I just remember that
after that was over,
I remember I ended up getting
drunk for the first time
with him and his friend,
their names were Colby and Dylan
and he ended up putting
Adderall in my alcohol
and drugged me.
14 years of knowing
someone maybe a little less
you're supposed to trust them.
The one person that stuck
through the rape case with me
not even the case I didn't
go to court or anything
but ended up raping me
and his friends raped me
and the only reason I
knew is 'cause I woke up
with fingertips on my legs
and hand prints, palm prints
on my hips from that.
I'll never forget that
the one person I loved,
the one person that cared about,
one person that was in
a relationship with,
the one person I trusted did what he did.
And just acted like it never happened
and went on with his life like
it wasn't even that he
acted like it didn't happen.
He knew he was guilty
and couldn't say sorry,
and own up to it cause
he's a fucking coward.
And that's all I see in that person
is like he knew I loved him.
And when we broke up,
I wasn't willing to go back
to being this girlfriend right away.
So he lost his power so he
had to get his power back
by raping me, by abusing
me, wanted power over me.
And I know that Colby,
I heard went to parties and raped people,
but the other guy wasn't like that
and maybe he influenced
him to do it or something.
I don't know.
But all I do know is that,
it was bad 'cause I went
from one rape to another
but the next rape was my best friend.
But after that I ended up
feeling like I was stronger
and that I could move
on fast at that time.
Maybe I just was so
damaged by the first one,
the second one wasn't as bad.
But after that I ended up,
I think getting with someone else
for about three years, two and a half
and I fell in love with that guy
and he was Steven, he
was a really good guy.
Had a lot of problems,
I accepted those problems,
but it was like he lied too much,
he couldn't be honest.
It didn't matter how much
you tried to work with him
he just, his self got in the way.
So actually three years we broke up.
I got with someone else
I was with for a month
but I think it was a month or two
and the first time I've this guy,
because the other guy I
didn't think I could get,
like I wasn't using birth control
we weren't using condom for three years
and he didn't get me pregnant.
So I thought maybe I'm infertile
maybe cause he said he wasn't infertile
so I thought I was in infertile.
And then I came to find
out in my next relationship
on the first night I got pregnant.
I was definitely fertile there
was nothing wrong with me.
And I told him like
when we had sex like there's a possibility
I could get pregnant,
probably should use a condom
but if you don't want to fine.
Well I ended up getting
pregnant and he ran.
He was like I wouldn't
mind getting you pregnant
and then that's how that started.
So it was like, I made a stupid decision
and but now I have a daughter.
So my daughter is fucking great.
But besides the point
he ran he was never there
for me during my pregnancy,
abandoned me.
I remember he came to the sonogram
and he told me that he wishes
he had given me a plan B
after seeing his daughter
alive and moving.
He wished that he wished he'd
killed her after seeing life.
I saw it in my head, like you're sick,
but I just let that slide,
I didn't really like say much to it
'cause it wasn't much to say to that
but after that found out my
dad was dying from cancer.
He's stage four, pancreatic cancer
and then after that I
was kicked out by my mom.
She left the note on the door saying that,
"you're no longer welcome back
here at six months love ya."
Not I love you, love ya.
She didn't even let me get my stuff.
I had to call the cops to go back up
and get some few items that I needed
and she blamed me for a divorce.
Which she calls herself,
she controlled his money.
She dug herself a hole and on top of that,
he wasn't happy he cheated on her
with her high school friend
which wasn't okay on his part either.
They both did wrong, but
they didn't communicate
or talk about it.
And I was like horrible.
But I remember I was standing
up for my mom so hardcore.
Literally not seeing
that she was manipulated,
took me getting kicked
out to see my true mom.
So after that, it was
like I was kicked out.
Now I'm six months pregnant
about to be homeless stole
my money at $3,000 saved up.
Stole all my money and kicked me out.
So I got a homeless shelter.
Don't have a ride there,
don't have any clothes,
don't I have anything.
Luckily I was dating a
guy for like a weekend
him and his mom took me in.
And I stayed with him for awhile
and it was really hard
because I was very vulnerable
like that person did a lot of hurt.
And I was gas lighted
a lot and I was raped
and he said that it was
because he was drunk
and he couldn't remember.
And I questioned that,
but I tried to talk to him about it later
and he just justifies it
like nothing happened.
So even talking to him about
it, he couldn't do that,
it wasn't possible.
I mean, I loved the guy,
but it was impossible.
He helped deliver my baby so,
and took me in when I was homeless
so was it that I wanted to be there still
or was it that I felt entitled to be there
because he helped me out
through the hardest moments.
Because I was supposed to be loyal
to people that helped me out.
But it was hard, cause I
don't wanna make him mad
or make him feel upset
'cause it was always so bad.
We'd have screaming matches.
But I ended up getting my own place.
And then I made the mistake of
after that place going
back to my mom's house
for a little bit and I
realized she got too much
so I packed up my stuff and
I took a bus down to LA.
I moved down to LA and I
was down in LA for awhile.
And I didn't know if
I was gonna place side
put my daughter in a car
seat, packed two suitcases,
got on a bus and left.
Took a leap of faith into the unknown.
I didn't know if it
was going to have place
to know what was gonna happen.
But I had faith that like I'd be okay.
When I got there, I found a room for rent
and I made it.
I know I got my permit
through the first time.
I have my own place now and
no one can take from me.
I just, I'm doing better
than I ever have in my life
and I just started to
feel safe, comfortable
and for the first time I
felt like I was at peace
that I didn't have to worry
about abusive boyfriends,
bad friends, bad parents because now
I have the freedom to cut out anybody
that doesn't serve my purpose in life.
That was a blessing for
me to realize I'm an adult
and I have power over my life.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you now?
- 24.
- [Interviewer] 24
- Took me 24 years and everything
I've ever done in my life
everything that's ever happened to me
did it alone nobody was there for me.
Not friends, not family, nobody.
Maybe my friend Alyssa showed
up at the hospital to help me
but through the pregnant teen
she's always kind of been there for me
but through the tough shit I was alone.
- [Interviewer] It seems like
so many people in your life
have let you down in different ways.
- There was one actually
specific situation
that was really fucked
up more than anything.
I think this was worse than rape.
After I broke up with that guy,
I got with a guy named Sam.
He was really cool.
He was a tattoo artist.
I admired his art
thought it was beautiful.
I thought he was a beautiful person.
I didn't know at the
time starting to date him
that he was a meth and heroin addict.
The only reason I found out
was because he went over to a girl's house
and I didn't know where he was.
I thought he was cheating or something.
And he came back he was like,
"no, I'm a functional drug addict."
And I'm like fuck you
where's the motorcycle.
Perfectly fine he works 40 hour job,
I would never have known
like I know they always people
a lot that do drugs, right?
I don't even deal with them
but it was crazy because
I wouldn't have think that
he could function like that,
like someone on drugs couldn't function
and he did a really good
job functioning on drugs.
And then I found out later
that I was pregnant by him.
I ended up getting called
from a cop showed up
and told me I had to leave his property.
I ended up getting a call from his lawyer.
Basically his lawyer was trying
to force an abortion on me.
Trying to say they would take me to court
to like force an abortion
and then he would do all
these say nasty things
and then they're like,
"we'll pay you a lot of money.
We'll pay for your abortion."
We'll do this,
we'll do that.
Like, I felt like my free
will was taken away from me.
But like maybe that's what
you wanted was to hurt me
in that way 'cause maybe I have her in
but he wanted to really destroy me.
So when I went to the abortion
I went through it alone.
I remember that I saw the baby live,
makes Vanessa that'd be dead
it was really traumatizing for me.
I think that's the last
traumatizing situation
that I've been through.
And I don't think that guy will ever know
the damage he did to my life
and him being a meth and heroin addict
should know that things
can fuck up your life
and forever ruin it.
But instead he inflicted pain
like someone did to him that
caused him to take drugs.
Except I will never do
drugs because I'm stronger.
I don't need a fill boy,
just because I got hurt.
I don't need to hurt people
when they actually helped me.
- [Interviewer] And then at some point
you got into the porn industry.
- Yeah, I did.
Nothing much to say there it's just like
porn isn't really real, like realistic.
It's like they do make a
lot of money off of it.
But the real thing is
it's like filming a movie,
like the movie industry.
Cut, take, cut, take, cut,
take cut, take pay the people.
Just not like, it was pretty normal.
Porn is like working in normal job.
Except they think it's
like get more praise
than a normal job.
You get more of money than a normal job.
It's like one step down
from being an actual movie.
That's how I feel about that.
Never been traumatized by porn.
Never had anything bad happen.
- [Interviewer] So, I mean,
what is your view on the porn industry
and how is it?
Is it good or for women
or for people or men?
- Well, I feel like porn empowers women.
It's someone for some women
they have had abusive
relationships, abusive families.
And I feel like they come into porn
and they're making
money for a fresh start.
So that they necessarily wanna go
have sex for money on camera.
So that they realize that,
Hey, look, I can save money.
I can have a fresh start.
I can be on my own.
I don't need this abusive boyfriend.
I don't need this abusive family.
I can literally save my
money to build my life.
I can build credit.
I can save my money.
And a lot of girls do spend their money.
But if there were smart
they would save it.
Save, save, save buy a house,
buy or get their own apartment to start.
Build a credit.
Work on getting their car
if they don't have one.
Try to get their permit.
Take driving classes so they
can pass the driver's test.
There's a ways around things
when you're suffocating.
There's always resources.
There's always people are willing to help.
If you're willing to communicate
and don't be afraid to ask for help.
I do feel like porn
can empower some women.
There's someone that it
doesn't empower them.
And maybe that wasn't meant for them.
That's how I feel.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
it's certainly a career,
not for everyone, not for every girl.
- No, definitely not.
- [Interviewer] But you found
it empowering to some extent?
- I found it kind of boring.
Weirdly, I find that, yeah, it pays good
but I found that I really
at the end of the day.
I get kind of bored
just because it's like,
not that I don't enjoy,
like the times that I have to have sex
it's more like I feel like,
I just feel like it's
another job I'm doing.
Like there's this girl in the
industry, her name's Emma.
And like I really admire her
because she set out goals
to set aside her money,
build her credit, get her
first home on her own,
put a pull in like successfully
do what she's doing.
Take pride into it and look
like she cares about herself
and it looks if she's not
happy, she at least looks happy.
I don't know her too well,
at least she looks like
she's confident and happy.
- [Interviewer] She's supporting herself?
- Wait what?
- Yeah and I really admire her.
And I don't think like,
I know she's probably a
really guarded person.
Doesn't let people near
her and what to be honest
is like, I really like if I like ever got
the chance to tell her like,
Hey look you're a really awesome person.
I really admire you. I'd like
to be a good friend to you.
I could learn from you.
You could really teach me like things
and I would like to like,
be there for you as a person.
Like, I remember there's
days that she had bad days
and I texted her,
"Hey, how are you doing?"
Just cause I care about people
and I get worried and I see her upset
and I just wanna be like, are you okay?
No, is everything okay?
'Cause there's been girls in the industry
that have killed themselves
and I worry about anybody.
Like, maybe some fans harassing her,
or maybe something's going on.
I just wanna be there for that person.
Doesn't matter the person.
But I see I admire her
and that'd be any girl
in the porn industry.
I'd be there for them
like, no matter what.
There's girls that I look
after I keep close eyes on.
Not just cause if there's
a having a bad day,
they need someone to talk to.
I'd be the one person to call them.
I had their number.
I text them if I didn't social media
but I think Emma's achieved a lot
and I think she's come a long way.
And I think she's been in
the industry for three years
and she's a really cool girl.
- [Interviewer] So your view
on the industry is it's okay?
- Now mutual about it.
That's how I would say
my feelings are mutual.
- [Interviewer] Neutral?
- Neutral, yeah.
I don't have anything negative.
I think the positive I've already said,
but I don't really have
anything negative to say.
I think the only degrading
part about the industry
is when there's directors that force girls
to do things they don't wanna do
and won't pay them to go home.
'Cause it's not in our contract.
The contract we sign.
So when they take advantage of the girls
when that's not what
they're getting paid for,
and that girls are uncomfortable
and they're intimidating them
because they know they're vulnerable.
I don't like that.
So only the negative
thing that I would say
that's an industry where
I've heard from other girls
that directors do do that.
I haven't had that done.
And if it was me,
if someone tries to do
that, I am gonna leave.
Doesn't matter what you're paying me.
So that's how I feel.
- [Interviewer] Going through
all this stuff that you went through.
I mean, what do you feel is
the most important lesson
you've learned?
- Out of the things that I went through
are necessarily my fault but
as long as I can accept it,
I can be comfortable
with myself and move on.
Things happen the way they do.
You can't control them.
You can breathe in the moment.
Tell yourself it's okay.
Learn how to cope with it.
Learn to move forward.
Be strong, get back up and move on.
Nothing stopping you from
being a better bigger person,
going forward with your life.
You have to choose to do that,
nobody else steps in
your shoes within a day.
You choose to step in your shoes
and make yourself go forward.
- [Interviewer] All right
Maddy I thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Yeah, no problem.
- [Interviewer] I wish
you the best of luck.
- [Maddy] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.